but it's about so much more than that  it's about the fact that you can afford  that right I go to yoga with this girl  there's an eight carat diamond  engagement ring yeah the weed company  and drives an Audi so it's about more  than just it's about the fact that you  can't afford that okay well I'm just  thinking like  you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys  because I'm telling you know but not not  in a good way not in a good way I'm  telling you like my dad would if my mom  asked for that from my dad my dad would  have told her to go find a new boyfriend  because there's no way in hell he was  going to spend two hundred thousand  dollars on an engagement ring